he is the pride of college Cottage Grove
Minnesota and the whole damn country nay
the world fell in love with him when
American Pie hit theaters near you and
now soon in theaters near you and on
demand and digital on Friday September
20th bloodline a new psychological
horror film from momentum Pictures
good to see you Sean William Scott how
are you brother goodbye you doing well
do great yeah you were just asking me
who I think is gonna win it all in the
National Football League yes I told you
I think the Saints would and you
responded about last night's game and
talked about a psychological thriller
yeah yeah made a big mistake what was
your mistake I knew that I should have
watched the game all the way to the end
yeah my girlfriend was like it's five
minutes lapse she's like we do something
to that watch two games at that point
yeah
no no was the first gamers of first game
yeah I watched a little bit yesterday
too
that's like two days in a row of 40 yeah
and she was yes so she was like you know
do you really have to watch the last
five minutes I thought probably but
maybe we'll hang out okay
missed the whole thing miss the entire
the end well I don't know if you aware
you might have been traveling on the way
down but the stat I read out at the
beginning is that it was the first time
there were multiple lead changes in the
last single minute of a Monday Night
Football game ever oh really
so yeah that's nice so in the in the
biggest decades long history of Monday
Night Football
I missed the game well the first time
that's ever happened and it changed
leads three times they changed leads it
was a to write Christmas change leads
twice the Tet that the Saints were
leading than the Texans were and then
the Saints did yeah all in the last
minute since okay it's okay it's okay
it's all right it's not the best game
it's a marathon and I think you did the
right thing because we don't live in
your shoes we don't live in your world
right it's your world yeah and you I
think you did you you took the long view
you really screwed up Sean
you know my girlfriend preciate it so
she's not into football she's getting
there okay we met she's like I'm not
gonna probably watch football with you
and I said goodbye she's like and I
started teach her a little bit yesterday
she she sat down on the sofa for like
five minutes
she's like I really like this stuff
right and then she left and you know
it's funny here's a guy mean years ago
when I was on ESPN I was invited by the
Learning Annex to teach off a football
class to beginners what's the Learning
Annex it was something where you would
you would pay money to take a class and
it would be people professionals from
different worried overcome and be guest
lecturers in the classroom that you paid
to get into and what was your thing so
it was football 101 like if you're a
beginner let's have the guy from Sports
Center come in and teach the Learning
Annex and the place was filled with like
30 people and when it finally started I
did not prepare at all for thinking I
could just wing it and explaining
football to people who have no idea what
a down is or what a tackle is you had a
good time
oh my god it was an absolute mess to the
point where some elderly gentleman
raised his hand in the back of the room
halfway through and says to me why did I
pay money for this class if you don't
know how to teach football because I
brought my wife here to learn and yes
and I you know sometimes you have to
filter your thoughts before it leaves
your mouth you didn't do it this time no
Sean I I I did but I wish like I could
Costanza go back in time and show up and
just basically save this guy hey pal if
you actually talk to your wife on a
Sunday for the last 40 years you
wouldn't have to pay the money to come
here to the Learning Annex
you know what I mean you they so it
wasn't an easy it's not an easy game for
a beginner to kind of pick up like at
one point I'm like well me is down in
football you can get up and run unless
you're touched while your knee is down
but in college football the play is dead
and then the number of looks I got from
people were just fresh off fresh in from
like Europe who had no idea what
football was it was a total disaster so
you wouldn't you wouldn't teach my
girlfriend well I mean um it depends how
much you've been willing to pay me like
a hundred bucks okay hundred bucks an
hour 100 bucks an hour no okay but like
it's a four hour limit like it means you
gotta cram that in there I just got this
window and I gotta explain it is it's so
whacked out though it is a whacked out
sport to have to explain yeah you think
it's easy though right like yeah I was
trying to explain it to Michael it's a
very easy sport to understand and I
started going through with her and she
was like totally checked out we had the
actress Gillian Jacobs here and she
asked me how come they call it downs
shouldn't they call it chances and I'm
like yeah like third chance and five
second chance and ten yards for your
next position it's just it's bizarre all
around but like I'm saying I can help
you
but I also feel your pain it's not easy
to explain it I know somebody who's new
to this thing what's your team do you
have a team in the NFL I I like a lot of
teams but I like the Patriots I like the
the night king over there with his hands
raised okay so I started watching and it
fell seriously in 2012 my best buddy was
like you got a football in high school
but he's like you really got to watch
you're missing out and so you know when
I started I was living in New York and I
was I started watching I mean pretty
much every game I could I could watch
but yeah I just loved the Patriots
because they were talking about like Wes
Welker and obviously a guys like
Amendola and Edelman you know they
weren't a team
I mean I'm wrong but at least from when
I started watching it that they paid a
ton of money to like choir all these
huge stars like they just really so
incredibly well coached now I didn't
have that history of like they're
winning every single year know but they
also take guys like Edelman who was a
cast-off I mean like Welker was a
cast-off in Miami made him into a Pro
Bowler take a guy like Amendola was a
cast-off
rams and win championships with him take
someone like Edelman off the campus of
Kent State compared him from Y
quarterback to wide receiver it's always
a Super Bowl MVP yeah and now they're
just gonna they're just gonna take that
self-made man and Tonio Brown which by
the way he was when he lucky underdog
Antonio Brown here he comes
what seems like this the first time that
I can remember because I didn't watch
when they had Randy Moss I don't
remember when Rick where he was Oh
second yep yep but like first time but
they've acquired like a huge star like I
mean it's definitely the the most
talented receiver and with all due
respect to their MVP can it make the
most decorated nine years in the league
since Randy Moss without a doubt Sean it
was nuts just watching that game against
the Steelers I mean like the receiving
corps was just like out of control and
then you think they're gonna get Brown
it was like I was thinking like do you
think Brock's gonna come back I think he
is I mean why would you I think he says
it like I'm in the best shape I feel you
know how long do you say he would need I
don't for some reason come on I don't
know where this photograph came from he
took a photograph of all behind all six
Lombardi trophies that they have with
Jonathan John is on his Instagram page
and Rob took his shirt off yeah he's
right behind but oh my god I got 12 pack
and I even put a shirt on a few rips
like that by the way I don't know you
tell me aren't you ripped like that no
they're small shirts it's a great way to
cheat okay
I'm with the smedium wearing Sean
William Scott here on the Rich Eisen
show now last time you were here we came
up with this brilliant idea and it kind
of dovetails into the this film that
you're doing right now in bloodline yeah
well I I forget how we got onto this
idea but it's a brilliant idea the most
brilliant that we will redo the endings
of all sports movies but the sports
movies that always end with an upbeat
goes in the absolute other direct you go
dark we kill
know exactly we now hold on a second do
we say we're gonna kill everybody off it
so what you're so not everybody we
definitely are killing people though
okay so late so like
instance the end he died he said it was
like this hamstring exploded I think
internal bleeding internal bleeding it I
think his head like got broke it off
clean off his body entirely that's the
way I've been thinking about this ster
he gets carried off the field
yes yes yeah so actually he falls from
high up being carried off yeah so had a
victory agony of death yeah that's
probably how it started because as you
know I wish the worst for Rudy every
single time I watch it and it always
ends in an upbeat yeah so and so on this
too let's let's workshop this a little
bit here mm-hmm cuz many people that
cross your paths in blood line meet an
untimely demise that's right
so in the natural Roy Hobbs gets to the
plate you could see his scars from his
bullet wounds are coming apart at the
seams
yeah gangrene sets in yes he doesn't
even take his at-bat right or yes or he
takes his at-bat right yes and instead
of him when he hits like the huge home
run yes as he swings he's whole like his
guts exploding out like alien yes and
then they and then the guy who pitches
it goes in his eyes and everybody's like
and then the end okay I cut to black
what about what about cuz that might be
a little too gory well for the shock
value the lightning that strikes because
of the the boy this just hits him the
boy no no no no he dies first
oh no the lightning strikes Roy the bat
boys fine unless you should die too
though he's so annoying he's like here
you go really he pulls out his back just
like by the way though I did go to a
recent Red Sox game the bat boy is a
grown-ass man
like full-on at man groaning he was he
was Batman more Ramar or what if he had
the Curious Case of Benjamin Button
disease he's actually how would that
work I don't know that he's he's
actually
no cuz he's like four okay this Brad
Pitt was like when he was - he looked
like a super old man yes right exactly
maybe he wasn't a grown man oh man she
goes in Reverse I like it so what
happens in field is Sean William Scott
here what happens in Field of Dreams did
we hit this the last time the house goes
into foreclosure right and they build a
mall over the over the cornfield yes and
then when mall when they get that
baseball players come out yeah yeah
there are zombies oh and then stick
zombies oh there is huge this is a huge
one okay they devour Kevin Costner just
start pulling out his guts oh my god is
hard
oh my Grammys cut to black at the end
and so then definitely the the house
goes into foreclosure and they they keep
the foreclosure part of it over they
pave it over it burns down people
there's a Starbucks and a Sbarro's there
within five minutes okay that how it
works yeah pizza and coffee for everyone
to Julie I appreciate that you're
thinking of like branding brand stuff
you know getting it's kind of like we go
this route like they do with the Bond
movies right like bonding it's like the
Watchers Martin yes so this would be
great for our version because we can get
money from Starbucks and was it Sbarro's
yeah yeah yeah the pizza play I mean I
just chose one but they I normally see
you know in a mall yeah but who does the
voice again was a Gilbert Godfrey that's
right something like that I don't even
know all right and then what happens in
Bull Durham what happens at the end of
Bull Durham he gets you know rim Robbins
yeah I was gonna go dark at this year's
first his arm splits like Dave dravec II
yes right right at the right at the ulna
bone I don't even know is that a bone in
your arm I don't even know what that is
yeah I don't it good I don't know that's
really dark what's your dark thing right
now what do you got well I was gonna go
with a worse injury right okay you so I
mean who dies first is it Kevin Costner
again
you know he shouldn't sarandon die oh
god yeah yeah I don't even I don't even
think we could do anything like that
with Boulder holder was a tough one okay
about Hoosiers Hoosiers oh man
Dennis Hopper kills everybody everybody
I'm so drunk you're all dead right she
goes like his apocalypse now character
shows yes yes oh my god why no but at
least they'll find out what the flavor
of the gum was if you got to keep that
still you gotta at least kill me
what do you think about your new film
sir it is pretty damn dark in its own
right bloodline again in theaters on
demand and digital on Friday September
20th what do you think it's great I mean
I don't get a chance to say that often
about the movies I'm in like this one is
like I've always wanted to do something
dark obviously yes and but it's like
it's a very it's a cool like kind of
throwback to old Brian De Palma movies
it's got a little bit of a Dexter vibe
but it's his own thing where it's really
stylized really dark kind of a quiet
little psychological thriller I love it
well the Dexter stuff is that people are
dying because they have done wrong
themselves I mean it's got a little bit
of the I'm totally blanking what is it
like when yeah vigilante it okay Joel
antiva it's got a little bit of that but
um but it's dark okay it's really really
violent it doesn't hold back at all okay
and again that's in so it's for mature
audiences kids - kids - kids yeah bring
your kids right there and you play the
role of Evan Cole in this film yeah and
and good luck with to you with all of
this brother absolutely
how much do you still hear about
American Pie how much do you hear about
that not too much too much I mean like
well there was like the 20 year
anniversary of the movie not long ago
which was wild tween it like we didn't
celebrate it right it's like 20 years
ago the movie 20 years ago 21 you know
it's 1999 it's when American Pie
you can't make that movie today though I
mean like I honestly I've always said it
like I think kids there's now the
teenagers are like they would watch that
and be like sex with a pie like it's
like oh that's crazy
witty or we do right I know I mean it's
like a cartoon for them well then they
also show it on their phones too right
you know we definitely clear the video
of me doing that you know here it is I
actually tweeted it out I put it on my
Instagram totally different a totally
different arrow but I remember when that
came out it was I remember seeing it in
a theater and they were way laughing my
ass off that's awesome just beyond
fantastic you were fantastic you're very
very believable its Stifler yeah you
should teach a Learning Annex course on
how to be how to bring out your inner
Stifler with that William Scott see
reality TV show we got to get in the TV
world as well we're gonna do our dark
movies and a little spin on the sports
yes but this is a this is a good reality
TV show I'm gonna go out there at the
Learning Annex and tell it tell
everybody how to be either best Stiffler
how do you get your inner Stifler
everybody yeah big box man we're gonna
make the big bucks you know you and I I
don't know how many guests we have here
where we just spit ball we spit ball and
try and make each other better and you
have done that with me sir
thanks again I really appreciate that
you're the best brother you come back
anytime you want thank you so much Sean
with two N's and scat Sean Scott with
two T's Sean William Scott check him out
on Twitter you know Jay men in the Grimm
no you know what
much nicer platform though people are
signing their lies they don't even
listen to my voice messages though so I
think I would what I'm like I'm the
worst person was like texting and voice
messages I just would be terrible on the
gram how do you communicate with people
like verbally like blinking
well I'm glad you don't do that here
this on radio that would be pretty
terrible you just blink twice everybody
I know what that means
check out bloodline in theaters on
demand digital on Friday September 20th
Sean William Scott got to see you here
for more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR live or download the Rich Eisen
show app